welcome to this new video about the
eighth round edge of the view tournament
and I must say it's really brilliant
tournament with such a low rate of
drawers all the size of games also this
round there was no draw this round and
it's really a tough race for first place
um yeah let's talk about the game's
first that I won't feature on Magnus
Carlsen one again against Victor Boone
Logan who continues to play rather
enterprising opening so despite his very
low score he played the bangko gambit
turn against Magnus today and what can
you say magnets took the pawn and yeah
converted this it's um I don't know
rather risky choice maybe at this level
to play this opening I think eid enough
to move 20 or something I think Magnus
was clearly betand just won this game
native a bit simplified this who this
description but it's not so far from the
truth I guess and we also had a TN back
row against um anish giri was also
fighting so for first place with the
great tournament and gear we actually
managed to win with black in a very
sharp game we're back row i launched the
kingside attack end yeah the whole board
was uh yeah was burning and i know maybe
it could have gone either way but at the
end them giri one and he is still in
contention for the tournament victory
the third game was Nakamura with white
against wrong how and yeah very very
clear this game the yeah Nakamura needed
to win to get close to something to to
the top in this tournament and wang hao
in an ideal world also would like to win
of course but of course losing would be
very bad as Magnus was huge favorite
today against bollagan and won this game
so wrong how yeah surely should
window at least draw this game to stay
in contention after he lost yesterday
against Magnus so I really am a very
good starting point for this game foot
for big fight and then I can we replace
he form he mixes his move so c4 again
and we got an English opening here woody
five and now it plays g3 this is a
rather yeah a bit uncommon move out of
it it's got some specific ideas Nakamura
oleum not sure this year or last yeah i
think this year even he played a game
with this line is wide and then here
played the the amazing new concept with
III III followed by night e 2 + + f form
against navara very really a new idea in
this kind of position and he want a nice
game so maybe he was aiming for for this
kind of setup but long haul played c6
the very classic answer to this which um
was this is named after pork eres um
yeah okay um account played 93-year the
point of the c6 move actually is that if
white continues with the normal looking
you should g2 then black can play d5 and
here at first you think why does it's
just winning this pawn or winning
something on b7 but black has some this
kind of stuff and black gets a huge
compensation for his pawn something like
this and this is why Drita fights for
his life here it's not it's not
advisable to play like this so of course
some nakamura avoided the simple 893
attacking this pawn and like it grants
if not much choice and here queen bee
six attacking the knight directly yeah
you three is also not so great so you
need to
move this night again and now on our
plate very concrete a five a checking or
intending to attack this night which has
no square actually white needs to do
something concrete now to save this
piece and he plays d3 the idea being
that is revealed in the game black
played a for now and now plate we should
be three gaining a temple on the Queen
so that after Queen move the night has a
nice square yard e2 and a very uncommon
position as arisen here before I
defaulters very strange pawns yeah blank
now captured on d3 and here we see him
very interesting choice I think good
choice but interesting nonetheless um
nakamura no took on a form and the
problem was that if you were to take on
d3 which looks like a normal move then
black has the very annoying answer a
three and what should why do now you
don't really want like to take on me too
but yeah maybe you need to the problem
being that the normal looking move b3 is
answered by Bishop before and now you
see this is a pretty uncomfortable pin
and this nigel has lost this footing on
on c3 the B to pawn it has moved and all
these black squares are rather weak so
for example something like Roxy one and
now defined with the idea deform is
already a very good for black it's um
yeah quite a strange strange setup here
with the same phone but it's very good
for black okay so this was not possible
the simple recapture I mean this him so
we needed to take here basically not
done much else and now black played d5
striking in the center yeah well here
here you still have issues with the with
taking on d3
you play Bishop b6 but let's look
briefly if it would have taken if y
takes now then the problem is this move
with the tempo and now there are
different possibilities the main problem
being that this night doesn't have a
square even be 54 mediately is something
to consider not sure if it is so great
but you can consider this let's just say
something like this and you still have
no no idea what you go with this piece
it's rather complicated but of the
rookies attacked so if this rope moves
then be a designing it's complicated but
black doesn't need to play be five
straight away you can also play a normal
move like I know this year and yeah
intending to play this also queen a5 is
a problem so it's not advisable to to
recapture very complicated stuff right
in the first moves I'm not sure I also
doubt that this is some sort of
preparation what they were playing
rather quickly I just just saw it ok so
late we should be six after some thought
I checking the the Queen yeah and the
Queen no need to move Bishop c5 are
taking the Queen again and it went to
see seven yeah now he took on their fate
and King recapture so why does succeeded
to exchange this III Bishop 58 bishop
but like has lost the right to castle
and while the king is not a problem
really it's not in danger but black
needs to do something with the rook on a
shade very unconventional position here
queen bee three plate which also takes a
look at the b5 square so that b5 is yeah
it's harder to play for black and also
white might intend to move the night
even to be 6 so now bd7 is very
understandable to keep the snot out of
play TM acara took on d5 yeah black
recaptures I don't know I didn't have it
would have been idea 95 wasn't
move whatever god he played Queen fi
which is also very interesting to set up
this pin and this is a main theme now of
this game said that white has got
slightly badly coordinated pieces and he
still has got to the king only one which
also doesn't help the rock so it's a
very complicated position he now grabbed
on c6 and now actually yeah white has
some has an extra porn but it's a very
difficult position to play because of
the somewhat less than perfect their
piece coordination the night job back
not much choice and here Queens Knight
c5 was played and Quincy form I also had
a brief look at them the alternative
quindi one here the sort of yeah it
looks sort of passive but maybe it's an
idea to to cover this night but black
has a very nice compensation just with
normal moves like Bishop f5 and rook the
aid to come white really has problems
with getting his pieces out so black is
some I think you're quite okay he can
also think about moving the age porn to
get the rook into play or just play g6
King g7 rupee aid stuff like that like
has very nice own compensation so I
think Quincy for was perfectly all right
also yeah threatening something um he a
black played the 95 which is really a
sharp move he could have also considered
to to take on e 2 which would have been
simple but but fine i think white
recaptures and then this bishop a six
and then I think white has not much
choice he needs to to play before to get
rid of pieces and something like this
might might follow and this should be
around equal
but maybe black was already thinking
about more he decided to play this 95
north which is which is interesting of
course white now capture the light
recapture and queen air form yeah you
could also think about 25 but while this
is really risky there should be seven
check here and then you need to play
something ugly like f3 and my first
instinct was ok this should be downright
awful for white but it's not so easy
actually maybe you can think about this
but it's for for human it's uh it's so
ugly this position hard to believe maybe
h5 now with this idea like has huge
compensation for two pawns I mean I
would take like in an instant here so
I'm ok it's very understandable that
Nakamura dignity captured d5 but just
played queen air for which also cover
the sensitive night yeah TM black plate
96 or taking the Queen G which gave a
check kingi age and now III and yeah
white sort of manage to quieten down the
position of it but you still have this
pinning business going and it's still
difficult really difficult to play
Bishop age 69 a six now to to cover the
d3 poem yeah here white had a choice
nakamura played Bishop g2 which i think
is okay and there was an alternative and
going Bishop h3 also attacking the night
with this this possible idea 95 and then
flew into play B form the problem is
that night b3 was threatened with the
sort of
strange double pin but be here before as
possible something like this just just a
sample line it's far from forced and
then castles because both nights are
actually hanging and you could get
something like this with the tag on f7
and this actually end very nice for
white you will get the deep on and have
have an extra porn at least an extra
porn so I think maybe Bishop h3 was
worth considering but it's a really a
tough position to play with the not much
time on the clock but ok white had some
extra minutes compared to one how it was
really down on time but Bishop g2 is not
not bad it seems rook the eighth
checking the queen with John year tuned
to move course and now h5 very
understandable need to get the rogue
into place somewhere and even attending
h4 so wyd reacted with a normal-looking
move h form stopping blacks h pawn and
now the mentioned rookie six and A three
also good move with the idea of playing
before to finally get rid of this pin
the thing they really did a good job
here very good good play and now before
and like play default need to get
forward somehow if wide manages to
cancel and get one or two extra moves
then like it's a rack he needs to get
things going quickly and this is also
good with the idea of getting the
nitrous III and we see one how he and
huge time Roger trouble he's on 30
seconds now camera castles
andrew p8 gaining a tempo and now the
night goes on this mansion route like
still down on time he gained a little
bit of time because of the 30 second
increment 93 93 and TM in this position
I think now camera media made a mistake
but it's a super difficult position it's
very easy for me to to look at this and
check out the ideas with the computer
and say okay this is a mistake and so on
I mean it's usually complicated Black
has although some counter play ideas
with this deep on the night here the
night only two is really a monster piece
on t3 already strong with only two it
also has the seed as a g3 pawn on the
text so that droop GA deserve is a
possibility rub g6 our energy a trip to
six also pointing here so I'm like I'm
gonna play tonight to d2 back to to
cover the pawn amongst others I think M
if you look at it with with a comp it
tells you 95 it's actually ok 44 white
um a possible continuation would be a 9
2 into 2 h 2 group 26 just a sample line
and white can retreat Yemm black would
play Queen g6 and as I mentioned it's
got everything on g two three and this
is one problem this is very hard to
cover this is actually a draw already
because some white zone needs to do
something here if you place the move
like this then I can actually even
sacrifice on g3 so blacks counterplay is
very strong and this is some strong [ __ ]
with the pet show
it's just a sample line to it's very
hard to to do a really a deep analysis
because there's so much possible to
Jesus in this position for instance here
instead of this move white could also
i'm the queen somewhere else let's say
um let's say to UM to to d5 and it's a
whole different story so um the the
point is really he needed to go night c5
because 92 I'm leads wide into huge
trouble but it's very difficult to play
this and very difficult to see the
problem is really this this issue with
the G 392 and root g six or pile up on
the Jeep on which looks very nicely
protected but the other issue also is
that White's queen is a bit short on
squares here it only has got squares
where you don't really want to go to so
we can check out alternatives here now
can we replayed 93 actually and gave
away the spawn and the thing is where
would you go with the Queen like is
intending various very uncomfortable
moves 111 being rookie five and the
Queen doesn't have a square at all only
air for when it runs into 92 winning it
so what has to do something to get
squares for as Queen one IDM could be am
queen Jeff five to actually get this or
this square but then this also gives
black am a very nice some initiative
with them yeah with more than one move
actually I'm a very strange at least
perform for me um move as the computers
mafia that just Quincy seven I really
don't understand this movement I need to
be honest here one idea could be a to
actually do something like this or enter
with the Queen on c2 so of course
this computer moves if it tells you it
is the best one in this kind of
technical position the computers most
probably right but it's a very unnatural
move for for human player to play a
Quincy 70m but then it's already am
difficult for wide any way to to play
this position it's not the only move
that you can you can think of um also
just piling up here as I mentioned it's
rather dangerous it's not at all easy to
play for white the queen is just just a
problem peace he wouldn't have this
issue with the night on c5 to console
nylons you have also control some
squares actively so at the end he
decided to play 93 and as you see he is
now down the clock as well very um very
end yeah a very big turn of events he
and it was rather unclear she moves to
go but now like really young yeah took
the initiative got the porn back and he
still has got this activity going he
coming out with rookie won a cool trick
but it doesn't really bring so big and
so big gains on one hand I played the
very cool new fruit h2e 6 I'm of course
the Queen was saying so what we need to
to check this if black would have taken
it then white can capture on the aid
with check g5 was checking it's all
checks him oops I love this move sorry
here why term can play the very
weird-looking move Bishop h7 which
attends a 94 with the checkmate even and
yeah black needs to do something about
this and it so the only move was really
this one and then you take him i confuse
this move order
Tia think white is somewhat better this
King here is a problem maybe if you look
at it deeper you can you can find even
something concrete for white but it's
definitely not a position you want to
play as black so on how played them this
rook H 36 move which is much stronger
keeping all the pressure intact you want
to keep your business en don't um yeah
don't enforce a very weird material
distribution where it's not at all clear
of your better and now the queen is
hanging for real it needs to move and at
the end he grabbed the h5 porn um it's
questionable if other moves are really
better one one alternative could have
been to retreat the Queen all the way to
to get to the square out so I still
covered but down black has more than one
good move one good move actually is
Bishop d7 redeploying this oops not here
but f2 is also a sensitive square it's
not bad but not by the not bad the
bishop so I'm Bishop d7 is a rather
strong move the idea being let's just do
a sample line that black is some
attending now to inveigh TM and I think
it's um it's almost impossible to to
hold this let's say rookie 6 and then
just just do this move and it's um yeah
it's really a big problem what what why
should play a let's say rookie one just
to give an example then like them play
this one and now it's gets very tricky
are the phone even threatening this move
and I mean this pawns here we'll just
decide this game yeah black just has a
huge initiative now and I think it's
just lost it took age five and then D to
the deep on enter
not much to do what should what play me
move the rock away and now Bishop e2 it
looks bad at first but it it's actually
I'm dead lost it's not like you can do
anything one problem being that the
simple reply here shows that this Bishop
poem yeah as also set up appt in here on
the Queen so what should why do we
cannot even sacrifice the exchange and
there's simply no move if wipe would
play something like this removing the
rook then yeah then blackened can
already strike with the night x f2 and
this is yet just winning instantly the
point being that this song via text the
g3 porn and white cannot cover it just
just terrible here you can just capture
and it's all over stuff like this and
it's it's dead loss yeah white gets just
destroy now he played the Queen 85 and
here Wang Hao played it simple
understandably with one minute on the
clock here even this was possible with
an instant win but it's not it's not
important he just grabbed this this rook
and in this position played this move
also very strong really am tearing open
whites whites position I think this is
very very strong player with one minute
on the clock very decisive you also
could have played any move you've got an
extra exchange but just just just yeah
killed instantly what should why do he
am yet the end captured on d to but
there was not much else if you take him
then this move simply decides because
this fret oops this fret here it's a
yeah you can not nothing you can do
rookie one just wins next move and the
combined forces of black can lead to a
medium so we cannot capture young g3 and
so what should you do well as mentioned
he captured but now this rookie one just
decides instantly he grabbed it yeah and
here white goes King edge to it's just
direct made can do this one and when
it's when it's checkmate quite nicely
here yeah so white couldn't do that
let's return so on rook takes you one
check he actually still played Bishop f1
and after yeah I didn't even know wait
sorry didn't even a white black smooth
we can just play here threatening queen
age to checkmate the rookies hanging and
black as a piece up and everything at
once so I'm complete one for black yeah
very nice win by one half at the end
from a really totally am weird unclear
position I think I'm the the main point
here was so this 90 to move which
somehow led to huge trouble for white
but it's very hard to spot because it's
very natural to to block the porn also
um yeah a very important game of course
for the tournament as now we we are
clear that the leader um yeah the winner
of the tournament will be decided among
cards in one how and geary carlson and
one how both have 16 points in this
three-point pouring scoring system and
geary has got 15 he's just one point
behind all three playing a great
tournament
actually Magnus with this win today has
come about five points short short about
garry kasparov small-time yellow record
of 2851 and if you would win his last
two games he would actually break this
record I'm not sure if it is very
important for him because I think it's
very obvious that he will break this
record anyway it's just a matter of time
and I also bet you know if you play so
let's say 45 years or so we will also
see 2,900 I would take bets on that all
right so thanks a lot for watching I
think a very very interesting fighting
game think for the fans of your car or
not not a good day but it happens if you
player that enterprising and aggressive
chess it just happens that once in a
while you get lost in the complications
and one how really did a good job I
think to to get compensation and
complicate matters e.m yeah thanks for
watching and talk to you soon i think
probably with round nine